salut j'espère que vous allez bien
depuis deux jours et que vous commencez
à profiter de vos vacances si vous êtes
en vacances aujourd'hui loin de moi
l'idée de concurrencer jonathan de la
chaîne du tattoo mais je vais vous
expliquer une petite expression et au
cours de l'été il ya quatre expressions
que je vous expliquerai d'ailleurs c'est
pas vraiment une expression c'est un mot
c'est le pique nique comme cet été vous
allez sûrement pour peut-être peut-être
pas faire des pique-niques j'ai trouvé
ça intéressant de parler de l'origine du
mot parce que le mot pique nique c'est
très bien ça remonte au moins au xviie
siècle peut-être même un peu avant et au
tout début pique nique ça veut pas
forcément dire prendre un repas dehors
ça veut dire prendre un repas un peu
simple en tout cas sans prétention où
chacun peut amener quelque chose dans
pique nique on entend de choses il ya
piqueté yannick noah d'avoir parlé
pic-pic ça vient du verbe piqué qui veut
dire picorer butiner un petit peu et
donc de nick alors nick n'a aucun
rapport avec le verbe nick est telle
qu'on l'emploie aujourd'hui il n'y a
rien de sexuel désole à l'époque le
terreau monique désigne quelque chose
qui a pas beaucoup d'importance qui n'a
pas beaucoup de valeur donc on disait
pas un pique nique mais une pique nique
ce qui signifiait littéralement faire un
repas avec des amis où chacun apporte
quelque chose ce sont des petits riens
sur lequel on va picorer à droite à
gauche et ensuite on s'est fait voler
par les anglais au xviiie siècle qui ont
pris le mot qui lui rappelait pique
nique pays cni sait qui est devenu du
coup masculin à l'époque quand il est
revenu chez nous et au 18e quand les
anglais ont pris le mot c'est là que ça
commence à vouloir dire prendre un repas
à l'extérieur
j'espère que ça vous a plu n'oubliez pas
de lire et de vous abonner je vous
rappelle que jusqu'au 30 août ont fait
une vidéo tous les deux jours sur un
petit truc comme ça rapide pour l'été
pour se détendre
donc rendez vous après demain ciao